(upbeat music)
- All right, y'all, welcome back.
Daisy Ridley is here.
(audience cheering)
Our next guest is another businesswoman
and the star of her own reality
show, "Vanderpump Rules."
New episodes air Tuesdays on Bravo
and streams starting
the next day on Peacock.
Please everybody welcome Lisa Vanderpump.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
I'm just saying,
that belt buckle is very Texan, I like it.
You came out and that's all I saw.
Yeah, that's all I saw,
I was like that's wonderful.
Have y'all met each other before?
- No.
But we are Brits-
- Hello, yes.
- And we both went to boarding in school,
I was watching.
(both laughing)
Yes, a lot in common.
- How are you?
- And I speak French so
I can teach you French.
- Oh, my gosh.
(Lisa speaking French)
- Sexy woman, okay.
- Wow.
- Duolingo would love you.
So how are you and your grandson?
This is exciting.
- Yes, well he's two years and two months
and it is the best thing
that ever happened to me.
He is just everything.
And, you know, I get so
emotional talking about it
because I loved my children so much
and I didn't know how it was going to be.
- Yeah.
- And then he was here
and I just cannot believe
it didn't happen sooner
because it's the best thing.
And he calls me Nanny Pinky.
(audience laughing)
- Nanny Pinky?
- Nanny Pinky.
And all I wanted for Christmas,
'cause he's just, you
know, starting speak,
was to call me Nanny Pinky.
And sure enough on Christmas Eve he said,
"I love you Nanny Pinky,"
and that was it, that was it.
- Like that's my gift.
- I couldn't have asked for more,
I couldn't have asked for-
- Oh, I love that.
Well, the best part too
is that you get to send
them home with your kid.
I think that's why it's
so enjoyable (laughs).
- It is, knowing you have that option,
but I don't like sending him home.
I love him.
I mean, Pandora's very, very, you know,
kind of hands-on mother.
- Yeah.
- But it's no coincidence
that I live a hundred yards
around the corner as well.
- Oh, that's wonderful.
- Yeah, maybe she doesn't
think so (laughs).
- Who cares?
Now you have a new restaurant
and it's called Wolf, right?
- Yes, I named it after him,
his name is Teddy Wolf
and it's opening in Lake
Tahoe in a couple of weeks,
if ever I get back there
and do what I'm supposed to be doing.
But very-
- Teddy Wolf.
- Yes, well it's just called Wolf,
it's Wolf by-
- No, I know, just that
he named Teddy Wolf,
that's a very great name, yeah.
- Well they talked about
his second name being Bear
and I was like, no, no.
If he's gonna be a
United States president,
he cannot be called Teddy Bear, so.
(all laughing)
- [Kelly] I didn't think about that.
- So yeah, the new
restaurant's called Wolf
and it's exciting.
With another one with Caesar's Palace.
- Yeah, is this the third?
- Third, and then I'm opening the fourth,
which we named after me,
Pinky, my nickname.
- Yeah.
- And it would be Pinky's by
Vanderpump in the Flamingo.
So yeah, it's so super, super busy.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
(audience cheering)
- That's my restaurant in Paris Casino
and we designed it in Caesar's.
- Yeah.
- And it was just,
I think voted like the 10th or 11th
most photographed restaurant
in the United States, so.
- That's so cool.
- Yeah.
- You are so successful at it-
- Oh my God, look at you.
- People love it so much.
- Look at you.
- No, I'm just saying like,
what is it about Vegas?
'Cause you keep opening your restaurant,
they're wealth because you keep
making money at it probably.
- No, no, but it's like it's Vegas
and I think even more
so since the pandemic.
You know, it was very
hard for restaurateurs
and a hundred thousand, more than that,
closed down in America.
- Yeah.
- And my hat goes off to anybody
that managed to keep their business afloat
'cause it was really,
you know, a struggle.
But I think Vegas is just so vibrant now
and people really go there to play.
- I love it, I go there
to do shows, it's fun
because you go in and out.
Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Great food, good shows.
- I don't go in and out,
I go and I stay there.
I love it, yeah.
- Oh, I'm usually in and out.
I want a good meal, some great coffee,
and I'll give a show (laughs).
Do you love Vegas?
Do you love going there?
- I actually, we took my
mom for her 60th birthday.
But what was hilarious was I was so tired
'cause I had been shooting
and someone bet me to ask for a hot,
you know, they'd like do your
drink orders on the thing?
- Yeah.
- Like someone said,
"I'll give you 50 bucks if
you order a hot chocolate."
I was like, "Okay."
So there I was like betting cards
and drinking my hot chocolate.
- Oh, I see.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It could have been worse,
it could have been a cup of tea.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah, throw some Amarula
in there, just saying.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it's a good day.
So wait, so your new season
of "Vanderpump Rules,"
like what's going on,
what's a tease for us?
- It was so complicated, you know,
and it kind of blew up
out of the stratosphere.
I mean, it was just so crazy.
It was a lot of bad
behavior the season before.
Yeah.
- And we tried to sort it out,
but we'd stopped filming
when it was all exposed.
So we need this season,
this season feels very
different to any other season
to sort it out.
And as the kind of matriarch,
do you ever watch the show?
You're looking at me like maybe you do.
- No, I'm just fascinated by
everything you do, I'm like.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Like what don't you do?
It's insane.
- Oh, there's a couple of
things, ask my husband.
(audience laughing and cheering)
- Stop it.
- It's the British humor.
- I have so many jokes.
They're so wasted right now.
God, I wish this was a nighttime show.
Well, we need another
commercial break everybody.
Watch "Vanderpump Rules" Tuesdays on Bravo
and streaming on Peacock.